- Let's call in my first guest, everybody
no matter the weather, he
always puts a smile on our face.
Like you I'm smiling right
now just thinking about him.
I love them.
You start every morning with
him on the Today show on NBC.
Let's say hello to Al Roker!
(upbeat music)
Yeah. You're feeling it.
You're feeling it.
Little body roll?
Yeah (laughs).
But you and Jenny have
something in common.
You also wrote some novels,
right? Which I didn't know.
- Yeah. I wrote three murder mysteries.
I've written 13 books in all,
but I wrote three murder mysteries.
"The Morning Show Murders",
"The Talk Show Murders",
"The Late Night Show Murders".
And they star this guy
named Billy Blessing.
I've always loved murder mysteries
and they say, "Write what you know."
So the first one was "The
Morning Show Murders".
So somebody on a morning
news program gets murdered
and Billy Blessing
helped solve the murder.
- So this is why I didn't know.
So my mother and like a lot of my friends
are really into a murder mysteries.
I don't think I've ever read one.
So now I'm gonna do it.
'Cause I didn't know this about you
and now I'm like really curious
to know about Billy Blessing
and who did it.
Now I wanna know who done it.
But who is Billy Blessing?
Did you, like I was telling Jenny
like some characters are kinda
inspired from my real life,
like Muses so is Billy Blessing,
is he based off anyone?
- Well, he happens to be a chef.
He's bald, he's chunky, he's black.
And he works on a morning show.
Hmm.
(Kelly laughs)
But the only differences is
he's really good looking.
So that's where we part in company.
- Whatever.
Since I saw you last I was sorry to hear
of your prostate cancer diagnosis.
So how are you feeling?
- You know, Kelly? I really feel good.
I was very fortunate. We caught it early.
It was an aggressive
form of prostate cancer
but we caught it very early.
I had a great surgeon from
Memorial Sloan Kettering,
Dr. Vincent Laudone.
And he feels we've got it all.
I'm waiting for blood work.
And once my PSA level is
below like 0.05 that means
there's no prostate cancer at this moment.
And what I'm gonna be
doing is getting tested
every six months for the next five years.
And if that turns out well
then it's once a year testing
for the rest of my life.
But you know, I went public with this
because I did want
people, it's a simple test
but a lot of guys, you know, we're wimpy.
We don't like going to the doctor.
And this is an easy test to do.
I mean, there's obviously the digital exam
where we all remember from
Fletch with Chevy, Chevy Chase.
Moon river!
(Kelly laughs)
- I love you (indistinct).
- That is in fact the gold standard.
And especially for men of
color, African-American men
50% more likely to be
diagnosed with prostate cancer
and twice as likely to die from it.
There are a number of factors in that.
So I just want people to get checked
get their prostate checked.
And especially if you're a man of color
get your prostate checked.
It's not that big a deal.
And it can make a big
deal because the fact is
if you live long enough,
my doctor told me you won't
die from prostate cancer
but you probably die with prostate cancer,
but making sure you get
checked, you can manage it.
- You have to. It's your body.
It's your temple. You
gotta take care of it.
And you gotta keep
checking up on yourself.
And I think it's so silly
and people are like,
"Oh, I just don't have the time."
I'm like, "Do you have the time to die?"
Like do you have the time to get cancer,
do you the time to do that?
'Cause anyway, I think
it's really important
that you did speak up
and you're open about it.
'Cause I think like you
said, maybe men are not as
excited to go do that,
but it is important.
And speaking of health, actually,
I love how open you are.
You actually got a COVID
vaccine live on Today.
Some think it's controversial.
So why was it important
to you to do on air?
- Look I think that, sadly,
I'm the only one (chuckles)
on the Today show old enough
to get the shot, I'm over 65.
And by the way, that ties
into the other issue.
You know, a lot of us, a lot
of people have been putting off
getting health checks,
normal health checks
because of the pandemic.
Either because they've had to,
or it's just been difficult.
And I think there's been some reluctance
for people to get it
and especially again, not to harp on this,
but people of color and
latinx folks have had issues,
they're in those communities,
getting the vaccine.
So I just wanted to go in there
and try to show people,
"Hey, look, this is easy.
"If you can get it."
Now, look, there are a
lot of issues with supply,
but I think it's important.
The only way we're gonna lick this thing
is for us to all take
responsibility for ourselves
and for other people.
So that means wearing a mask.
That means getting you
doing social distancing,
washing hands, and getting
your COVID vaccine.
- And so we can get our
lives back. How about that?
- That's right and in fact,
our parent company, Comcast NBC Universal
is trying to help folks, plan your vaccine
so that we all get together
and you can see our loved ones.
So all you have to do is
go to planyourvaccine.com,
sign up for an interactive site.
Gives you all the vaccine
information you'll need
in one place so that when
you get your appointment
you are ready to go.
- Right on. You should have been a coach.
You're good at it.
Well, hold on you have
a Today Show interview
special coming up next Monday, right?
Can you talk about it?
- Yeah. I'm pretty excited about this.
Of the first African-American
a Cardinal was named Wilton Gregory,
Catholic Cardinal was named.
He runs the archdiocese of Washington
so technically he is
president Biden's pastor
and I got to sit down with him
and he was not raised Catholic, but
his family migrated up
from the South to Chicago.
And once he got into Catholic school
he knew pretty quickly
he wanted to be a priest.
And we talk about the
divide in our country.
We talk about bias and race in our country
and how even as a man of the cloth,
he's had to deal with that.
So I really enjoyed sitting
down and talking with him
and we're gonna have that
coming up this coming Monday
on the 3rd Hour of Today.
It's a really interesting conversation
and I think we need,
we really do need to be
talking more and more
with our faith leaders
if we're gonna try to
unite people together.
- Yeah. Good gosh.
About time that's what you
should name that special.
About damn time (laughs).
You can see Al mornings on Today on NBC.